thank you thank you very much I
appreciate that it's too nice thank you
very much
so excited to be here you guys I come to
you today from the great state of
Colorado some people not that into it
that's just fine when obviously tell me
I was from Colorado the like oh that's
so cool do you ski and now everywhere I
go they're like Oh Colorado do you smoke
weed I was like no I don't do either I
knit and I take prescription plates and
then I just knit faster so forget what
you think you know about my state we get
real weird you guys excited for prom
this year who's excited for prom yeah
Saida we're all gonna have a good prom
season you guys you don't have to be in
high school to enjoy prom okay you just
have to eat a cheesecake factory during
the month of May or June to see all the
prom on display that pre-prom dinner are
you kidding me that's my favorite thing
ever
two seventeen year old sitting opposite
each other in ill-fitting fancy clothing
all full of nervous energy and
anticipation is tonight always want to
lean in that scenario just like I'm from
the future yeah it's weird I got a news
flash for you little buddy not only
you're not gonna make out with this girl
tonight but guess what else this is also
the happiest you'll ever be thank you
guys now come up to the card help me
finish this bottle of peppermint
schnapps I got out there
these blink 182 cities are not gonna
listen themselves we got a lot of crying
to do before we sleep tonight
I love performing stand-up comedy give
do cool things like this you get asked
to do cool festivals I got to go down to
South by Southwest last year it's big
Music Festival in Austin Texas a lot of
fun good time nobody warned me the
people in Austin Texas during South by
Southwest party like the earth is on
fire you guys end of days partying I
could not hang I just got into the
festival not even at the festival
checking in the hotel and I had to use
the bathroom so I'm in the hotel lobby
bathroom peeing when the door bursts
open and in walks this Texas stud
looking dude it's like Matthew
McConaughey compadre just cradling a
12-pack of Bud Lights in his arms like a
newborn baby and he sees me at the
urinal he goes hey man you here for
South by Southwest you want a Bud Light
before I could say anything he just
Chuck's one at my head and I was peeing
I'd even try to catch I just like ducks
hit the walls skin across the ground and
he looks at me and he goes you just step
your game up you're down one to nothing
and then he left like the coolest person
on the planet you guys that is not how
you relate to other human beings that'd
be like if I hid out in the park all day
long in the bushes just waiting for some
old man to come along and feed the birds
then as soon as he did I just jumped out
I was like hey quick what's the official
but state bird of Texas to slow kicking
the teeth that's not fair it's not fair
at all plus you guys are looking at a
former athlete okay I'm very competitive
so it makes me crazy
knowing that there's some guy walking
around Austin Texas up one of nothing on
me right now that makes my skin itch I
just got word I'm invited back to South
by Southwest this year I'm gonna carry
bud lights on my person at all times you
know eventually I'm gonna see that dude
I'll just jump out from behind a group
of strangers and tag on the back of the
head I'm like tie game McConaughey
he'll just be like alright alright
alright nice work little buddy student
has become the teacher I'm a big
baseball fan so I'm excited that it's
baseball season I listen to all the
games my hometown on the radio cuz I
hear the best ad I've ever heard in my
entire life it happens in the middle of
the game
fifth inning to be precise this guy
comes on he goes we reached the bottom
of the fifth if you reach the bottom of
your fifth head to Applejack liquors
that is a brilliant at in my head Don
Draper wrote that ad that's how good
that is cuz see the subtext going on
there it's like hey it's been 70 minutes
you put down a half gallon of vodka once
again the car and drive hero come on you
can do it you're fine
it's Applejack you got deals four days
due to previous contractual obligations
with the MLB Network this games in
blacked out in your area if you're
blacked out in your area headed to talk
about drive-thru get a stranger pregnant
who cares it's baseball season hope
springs eternal thank you guys very much